I'm in the center of town on my way to
new golf ski prospect number three
they're expecting me in one of the most
unusual apartments I have ever seen
first a hallway long and dark then 16
rooms with 16 families this is a
Komunyakaa a shared apartment a relic
from Soviet times it's like a journey
into the past in the heart of st.
Petersburg I meet the people who make
their home in the communica a whole new
value despite all the difficulties the
power lines from the 50s can be a
problem it's pretty awful here
the kitchen is the heart of the
community ah with clear rules and a
strict hierarchy those who have lived
here longer get the better parts that
means your own table and your own part
of the communal stove I was born here so
my husband and I are among the
privileged ones and this is our
privilege ku Monica's are an integral
part of life in st. Petersburg the
soviet-style collectives help people
feel less alone in the big city the
shabby communal apartments are a stark
contrast to the opulent tourist
attractions
and they're also right in the center in
the old town also a privilege I pay a
visit to the privileged residence in
room number three
mama Paulina and her daughter Alexandra
are getting in some early musical
education
it seems to make yo chic the cat hungry
papa Evgeny is trying to install a
heating and cooling system
for the winter they don't want Alexander
to freeze when the eto breaks down as it
often does Russian now is like the
Soviet Union of the 70s the economy will
ultimately collapse and a new life will
begin but not in our lifetimes so we
don't have big plans for the future
getting on with life no matter what
happens a typically Russian attitude
that's shared by polina's neighbors
there's no reason we can't be happy in
this country or to put it another way
there's nothing here we hate so much
that we'd want to leave of course Russia
has flaws but what country doesn't
a shortage of goods is something this
country definitely does not have
provided you have enough money to buy
them the produce at this nearby market
sells for Western prices even though the
average monthly income in Russia is the
equivalent of just 400 euros the mutton
has been requested by an Uzbek family in
the communica who are going to make a
probe a dish with rice back in the Komen
arcade the boundaries between public and
private realms disappear as evening
approaches especially as the aroma of
roasting mutton spreads the Uzbek couple
near Seoul and his wife whose name they
won't divulge would rather not talk
about Russia where they are guest
workers we just earn our money here and
that's more than in Uzbekistan who's
Becky stan is here in the kitchen with
rice and carrots and lots of meat a
piece of that was back south here in
northern Russia
if Gainey and Polina offer me chocolate
and chips this evening along with plenty
of communica philosophy it's all fine so
long as you remain in your own room I've
got to raise my voice to make sure the
communica stays clean sadly I wasn't
voted communica president and so I have
to constantly raise my voice and assert
myself and so democracy within the
communica remains fraught with
difficulties you might say rather like
in Russia as a whole
you